خلال مشاهدتك لشاشه التلفزيون لن تختفي
الاعلانات التجاريه التقليديه المعتاده بل
ستلاحظ زيادتها في شهر رمضان كالمعتاد
مثلا لكن على الرغم من ذلك يشير مختصون في
مجال الدعايه الى تراجع الاعلان التقليدي
لصالح السوشيال ميديا على الصعيد العالمي
تنفق الشركات اموالا على الاعلانات
الرقميه اكثر من الطرق التقليديه وذلك منذ
عام 2019 وفقا لموقع
السبب يكمن في نقطتين المؤثرون اصبحوا
وسيله جيده للعلامات التجاريه للتوجه
والتحدث الى مجموعه مختاره من الناس بل
يمكنهم ايضا التواصل مع الجمهور والرد على
اسئلتهم مباشره اضافه لذلك اسعار الدعايه
عبر السوشيال ميديا تعتبر اقل وارخص من
الوسائل التقليديه لكن يظل هناك راي اخر
بان المؤثرون هم وسيله مساعده لدعم
الاعلان الت جاري التقليدي خاصه للشركات
والعلامات الكبيره كون الاعلان التقليدي
لا يزال اكثر ابداعا بما يحمله من افكار
وقدرات تاثيريه